An important class of distributed memory
algorithmic primitives are the so-called
collective operations.
No, not that kind of collective.
One example of a collective
operation is a reduction,
which in the distributed memory case,
I will call all-to-one reduce.
The phrase all-to-one makes it
clear that all nodes participate
to produce a final result on one node.
Let's take an example.
Consider this linear network
which I've numbered from 0 to 8.
These ID,
numbers I'll sometimes call ranks.
So, for example,
the rank of this node is 4.
Now suppose each node has a single
value in its private memory,
let's say these values.
In an all-to-one reduction,
you want to produce a final result which
is the reduction, in this case sum
of all the values on a root node.
So the sum of these values
it turns out is 55, and
let's say we want that
result to appear on node 0.
Now intuitively, you expect a tree base
scheme like this one to work well.
It's span is logarithmic
in the size of the input.
In this case, there are P values.
Now, this observation suggests that
you'll need to perform at least log P
communication steps.
Now, initially, the data is
distributed across all nodes,
so no node can do any actual work.
Therefore, you'll need to
do some communication.
Okay, well that's easy.
Let's have all the odd number nodes send
their data to their leftmost neighbor.
So 1 will send to 0,
3 will send to 2, and so on.
None of these sends conflict so
all the sends can happen simultaneously.
So this round of
communication will cost you
alpha + beta time since
you're only sending one word.
After the communication,
the even ranks add the incoming value.
The new state of the system
then looks like this.
Now in this next step,
you'll notice that only even
numbered ranks have values.
So notice the even ranks
have partial sums.
So we can repeat this scheme,
except this time with odd partners
of the remaining set sending
to the closest even partner.
So we might do these sends, for example.
Again, there are no
conflicts in the paths so
this costs us alpha + beta time.
And you'll just repeat
this process until
a final result remains.
Now, to implement this scheme,
I want to point out a useful fact.
Suppose we replace the ranks by
their equivalent binary strings.
Recall that in the first round,
the odds send to the evens.
Notice the odds all have a 1 in
their least significant bit, and
the evens all have 0.
In the next round,
the only participating processes have
a 0 in their least significant bit.
And notice what happens.
Nodes with a 1 in their second bit
send to nodes who have
a 0 in their second bit.
So again, it's basically odds to evens
where you drop off the last bit.
Neat.
If you've heard of
things like hypercubes,
binary reflected Gray codes, or Hamming
distances, then this bit manipulation or
bitview of the world
will seem very familiar.
And if you aren't, we'll give you some
pointers in the instructor's notes.
Shave and a haircut, two bits.
I don't know what that shave and
a haircut two bits thing is, but
I got it from somewhere.